Sonne may owe you some sweet cash money
from all the way back in 2010 I'm Dave
and welcome to your GameSpot news
updates the ability to install Linux was
one of the reasons some users purchase
that older PlayStation 3 model
so when Sony locked out support for this
in 2010 not everyone was happy a
class-action lawsuit was filed against
Sony that year and now six years later
Sony has agreed to settle the case Ars
Technica reports that under the terms of
the settlement which has not yet been
approved sony has agreed to pay as much
as $55 to as many as 10 million ps3
owners to get the full $55 gamers need
to attest under oath to their purchase
of the product and installation of Linux
provide proof of their purchase or
serial number and PlayStation Network
signing ID and submit some proof of
their use of the other OS functionality
alternatively gamers can get nine
dollars if they attest that he or she
lost value and/or desired functionality
or was otherwise injured as a
consequence of firmware update 3.21
issued an April 1st 2010 only gamers in
the US who bought a fat version of the
ps3 between November 1st 2006 and April
1st 2010 are eligible for the settle
offer a judge will decide in July if the
settlement offered will be approved
according to the agreement which was
filed in court last Friday Sony will
reach out to customers via the
PlayStation Network email database and
then we'll also be internet banner ads
and search related ads on sites
including GameSpot and sister companies
CNET do you think sony was wrongly
removing the other OS feature are you
one of the people that could benefit
from this lawsuit let us know in the
comment section below or find me on
Twitter at irregular Dave and folio
gaming news stay tuned to games.com